The second place where the Quran refers
to the first 10 days of Dhu al-Hijjah is
in Surah Al-Hajj,
chapter number 22,
verse number 28, where Allah Subhana Wa
Ta'ala says that they witness
the benefits which have been provided
and they celebrate the name of Allah
Subhana Wa Ta'ala through the days
appointed.
Here, these days are referring to the
first 10 days of Dhu al-Hijjah.
And Ibn Hajar
al-Asqalani,
may Allah have mercy on him, he writes
in Fath al-Bari
that these first 10 days of Dhu
al-Hijjah are the only 10 days in the
full year where any Muslim
can simultaneously perform all the five
pillars, all the five fara'id of Islam,
if he wants to.
Yes,
he can
implement on the tawhid, he can offer
salah
simultaneously together in the first 10
days. He can give zakat if he hasn't
given, give obligatory charity, or give
extra charity. He can fast.
And he can also perform hajj. These are
the only days in the full year where a
person can simultaneously perform all
the five pillars of Islam. It is
mentioned
in Sahih Bukhari,
volume number two, hadith number 969.
Ibn Abbas,
may Allah be pleased with him, he said
that the beloved Prophet Sallallahu
Alaihi Wasallam said,
"There are no good deeds done on any
other days
better
than done during the first 10 days of
Dhu al-Hijjah, than during these days."
And
the Sahabas, the companions, they asked,
"Not even jihad?" And the Prophet
replied, "Not even jihad, unless
a person
puts in danger his life and wealth in
the way of Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala and
does not return with any. That means he
goes for Jihad and he's martyred in the
way of Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala. That
means our beloved Prophet Muhammad said
the good deeds done during the first 10
days of Dhul Hijjah better than any deed
done on any other days of the year,
including Jihad, unless if the person is
martyred and he loses his wealth and
life during Jihad. That's the only one
good deed
which cannot be better. Otherwise, the
deeds done
on the first 10 days of Dhul Hijjah are
better than any deed done on any other
day of the year.
It is so important.
And unfortunately,
this Sunnah of doing good deeds during
the first 10 days of Dhul Hijjah is
forgotten.
It's further mentioned in
in Sahih Muslim.
Point number three, Hadith number 2747.
When the Prophet was asked regarding
fasting on Yawm al-Arafah,
the Prophet said, "It expiates
the sins of the previous year and the
coming year."
That means
the most important fast after the first
fast of Ramadan is fasting on Yawm
al-Arafah. It expiates your sins of the
previous year as well as the coming
year.
There are some scholars who say that the
fasting
of
Ashura, the 10th of Muharram, is the
most important because there's a Hadith
that the most important fast after the
first fast is the fasting on Yawm
al-Ashura.
But there's a difference of opinion, but
the correct opinion is that Yawm
al-Arafah fasting is far superior
because it expiates the sins of the
previous year and the following year,
whereas fasting on Ashura expiates only
the sins of the previous year. But
there's unanimous agreement that these
two fasts of Yawm al-Arafah and fasting
on Ashura are the two most important
fasts after the fasting of the month of
Ramadan.
It's mentioned here
in Sunan Abu Dawud,
volume number three, Hadith number 2437,
that one of the wives of the Prophet
said
that
the Messenger of Allah fasted during the
first nine days of Dhul-Hijjah and
during Ashura and three days every
month, the first Monday and two
Thursdays.
So, from this Hadith we come to know
that the Prophet fasted the first nine
days of Dhul-Hijjah. That means it is
highly recommended
to fast on all the first nine days of
Dhul-Hijjah.
One may ask, "Why not fast all the 10
days of Dhul-Hijjah?"
The answer is given
in Sahih Bukhari,
volume number three, Hadith number 1991,
where the beloved Prophet said that he
forbade fasting on
Eid al-Fitr and Eid al-Adha. Well, these
are the two Eids of celebration, of
eating and drinking. So, it is
prohibited to fast on the two Eids then,
Eid al-Fitr and Eid al-Adha. That's the
reason we don't have to fast the first
10 days
of Dhul-Hijjah. Though the first 10 days
are the most important days of the year,
we only fast during the first nine days
of Dhul-Hijjah. It's further mentioned
in Sahih Muslim, volume number three,
Hadith number 2679,
the beloved Prophet Muhammad said
that no one shall enter Paradise except
a believer.
And the days of Mina are the days of
eating and drinking. That means a Muslim
should not even fast on
Ayyamut Tashriq.
The three days following the Eid
al-Adha. That is the 11th, 12th, and
13th of Dhul-Hijjah. Because these are
the days of eating and drinking and
feasting. So, besides the Eid day, a
Muslim should not even fast on the
Ayyamut Tashriq. That is the 11th, 12th,
and 13th of Dhul-Hijjah.